But how do trade barriers play out in the marketplace...
...particularly with respect to the American consumer?
You look at the Camry that we're showing today.
You know that car...
...has the most amount of domestic content of any vehicle made in the US,...
...75 percent, more than any other truck, any other car.
And if based on a back-of-the-napkin calculation,...
That car with a border tax...
...likely gets a thousand-dollar increase in cost.
Who will incur that cost?
The 1000 dollars?
We believe that that's not gonna be able to be absorbed by the manufacturer,...
...has to get passed on to the marketplace.
In other words, the consumer.
And as a result of that, we think it's going to reduce demand for automobiles.
We'll have to adjust our production schedules.
It's gonna have a negative impact on overall employment.